e
good afternoon everyone um I'm going to
call the meeting of the um study
committee to look at the impact of
disabilities on um folks with
disabilities and um this will be
recorded I see that all of the seats
behind the camera are
empty I guess you've all you all saw
yourself from the previous meetings um
Okay so so
um we're
um well let's let's just let's just get
started um I'm my name is Kathy stab I
represent um Hillsboro District 25 in
Ward five in
Manchester and Jessica L montin uh from
Dober
um we're not going we're going to move
um approval of the minutes to the end of
the meeting so we're going to begin go
right ahead with the
presentations from the um stakeholders
um so I would like to call Charles St
Charles seya um with the stable New
Hampshire program to come forward you
com okay for having us represent good
good afternoon for the record see
treasure Monica
mapelli and Chuck SE last name spelling
is s like Sam a i a executive director
governance Commission on
disability um and Cher star again once
again thank you for the opportunity to
present on New Hampshire and to give you
a very highlevel review of New
Hampshire's able savings program known
as the NH able plan um seated as as uh
Monica had stated uh the state treasurer
and myself the executive director of the
governor's Commission on disability uh
what is known as the
co-administrators of the able SA program
um in New
Hampshire so what I'll do um subject to
our approval um representative monik and
I will will um present um together uh
and again at a very high level because I
I know um you have an interim report
that's due and we wanted to ensure that
we gave you as much information as we
could um today and and obviously we're
we're more than happy to answer
questions and and in the upcoming year
to either come back or or address um uh
any uh questions that you may may have
so um just to give you an overview when
we look at um able the able Savings
Program um in our world we look at this
as truly a GameChanger because with able
savings accounts individuals with
disabilities are able to save money
without jeopardizing needs-based
benefits and typically those needs-based
benefits are SSI which is known as
supplemental security income as well as
Medicaid um
and coupled with that is that the monies
in the account can now be used on what
are referred to as qualified disability
expenses um I wasn't able to attend last
week's um Hearing in person but I did
listen to a uh rebroadcast on YouTube
and um what what you had heard part of
the tenor of the discussion from
consumers individuals and families of of
individuals with disabilities is that
there's that threshold eventally for
years individuals with disabilities and
their family members
understood that an individual with a
disability could only have so much in
assets and that was typically about
$2,000 if they exceeded the
$2,000 then that would jeopardize those
benefits that um we just spoke about the
U Medicaid and the
SSI so what occurred in 2014 uh Federal
legislation passed uh which was known as
the step Beck Jr of achieving a better
life experience act the able act um
which essentially um it became federal
law that now individuals with
disabilities could Now open up these
accounts and the states would then
follow with their own enabling
legislation um to allow for those
accounts in 2016 New
Hampshire um had its own um legislation
U which is now codified in RSA
195k and basically this authorized uh
qualified able savings accounts uh in
New Hampshire New Hampshire launched its
program in
2017 and at that time and it's
understandable because this program was
around for a good many of years at the
time New Hampshire's program was known
as stable St a b l e stable NH um and
that was in effect from 2017 up until
last year just about this time um when
the contract came up for Renewal uh
state treasur and myself uh as
authorized by Statute looked at the
program and said are there other options
that that may benefit um New Hampshire
um so at that point last year um we
continued with our obviously our able
Savings Program and now in New Hampshire
it's known as the NH able plan and we
did put brochures what we refer to as
Slimline brochures inside your folder um
so that that'll go over um exactly what
the account is about so again from an
administrative standpoint
um New Hampshire is now part of the um
the national able Alliance which is a
Consortium of 19 States and myself and
Monica will be the first ones to admit
we meet very regularly with our sister
States um at the national level as it
deals with the operation of um able
accounts um in New Hampshire there are
currently
1,184 um account holders uh in the state
of New Hampshire and that includes both
the Pharma stable as well as the uh NH
aable plan um New Hampshire has roughly
let's see 11.5 million in assets um
under advisement
nationally uh just to give you a
snapshot um there's
162,000 969 accounts nationally with
about 1.74 billion in assets so again
you know we're looking at in New
Hampshire 1184
um per the uh Institute on disability um
their most recent compendium on
disability statistics um there our
population in New Hampshire is about 1.3
million and there are 182,000
individuals um in New Hampshire per the
IOD The Institute on disability um that
do report um self-disclosing uh that
they have a disability so that that
gives you a a very that gives you an
overview of of administratively um how
the um how it works and from a very high
level again um when we're looking at the
New Hampshire able plan we've always
said from day one when we launched in
New Hampshire it truly is a game changer
for individuals with disabilities and
their families that that um threshold
the spend down that need to ensure that
you no longer have that
$2,000 that's now been that's gone
that's been eradicated with the
institution of the able Savings Program
um across the country um you know from
the governor's Commission on disability
we look at the Americans with
Disabilities Act as this Monumental
piece of federal legislation civil
rights but when we also when we when we
consider other um statutes ael's right
up there because it did it really it
transformed the landscape um so that now
individuals can save um in without
jeopardizing benefits and in conjunction
with that and I put it in the handout
when an individual is is looking at SSI
determination or Medicaid determination
I think it was back in 2019 HUD
essentially came out with a um I don't
want to say a report but essentially an
uh uh an edict that even housing
benefits Section 8 there are a slew of
other Federal housing benefits that if
an individual has in New Hampshire an
able uh an an NH able plan account again
that won't go into
determination um for those Section 8
vouchers and that other public housing
benefit so you have SSI um you have
Medicaid and for the purpose of this um
Forum to now think that housing also
excuse me what for purposes of the
public housing benefits the monies and
the contributions and the interest and
and I think the state treasurer would
agree with that everything in the able
account does not get counted um for
those Federal housing benefits and it's
they're elicit you know inside uh
handout we did put together um
references that that we can actually
send to you by email so that you can
hyperlink right over to them it may be
helpful um for your report so we're more
than happy to do that um great again at
a very high level in order to have an
account the individual um to be eligible
the onset of the disability um must be
by age
26 then there are other criteria and
really the criteria that is most often
talked about the individual um has to be
eligible to receive supplemental
security income or
SSDI um Social Security disability
insurance so those are typically the
determining factors so the individual
opens the account um a loved one can
open the account there's a hierarchy of
individuals that can open the account um
if the individual doesn't have legal
capacity to open the account parents
Guardians um can step in um if an
individual owns the account account in
his or her own name they can assign
power of attorney so that someone can
assist them in managing so again when we
look at it from uh the disability
Community it really we're we're really
expanding Freedom um we're ensuring that
individuals can can live independently
where where I look at this sort of as a
toolbox now as with the intent that you
have to look at the housing crisis which
which we know is is is a is a situation
that has to get addressed but now to add
this to the resources where it all
flushes out we don't know but again to
have able at least as something that
individuals with disabilities and their
families um are aware of so once the
money is in the account then you can an
individual with a disability can save uh
18,000 per calendar year um in
contributions which is huge um and in
conjunction with that if they're working
um they can add another roughly about
another 14,000 to the account and again
this is you know for determining SSI and
medic
these are safeguarded you know we're not
hiding assets here that that's not what
we're doing but we're actually putting
the money where where it can be um you
you know we won't get into it today
you've heard of Special Needs Trust
wonderful vehicles um many individuals
with disabilities don't have um a
special needs trust but able accounts
are not we don't encourage it that they
go to override a special need trust but
actually they work in conjunction with
them because the money's in a special
need trust and and hypothetically
speaking may actually fund the able
account um and once the money is in the
account the individual with a
disability can spend the money on
qualified disability expenses what we
refer to as a qde and typically a qde an
expense has a disability expense is
related to the disability and it looks
to enhance quality of life it is a
incredible full list of um items that
are under QD and it and it has a very
broad application uh personal support
services food um technology education
there is just a host and one of and
again for this um committee housing so
housing expenses be it be it a mortgage
be it a rent be It Whatever whatever the
uh utility bills whatever whatever the
individual is paying for housing if they
have an
account um it can they can then pay
those expenses there's also investment
options which I will turn over to the
state treasurer to discuss um because
again this is I should have said also
and this is really within the Wheelhouse
of our uh State Treasurer um able
savings plans were fashioned against
College savings plans so College savings
have been around for years um Advocates
as a story was told to me going back to
2014 and before essentially went to the
went to the feds and say well if we can
do this for other children and we can
say for college why can't we do the
similar for individuals with disability
so with that uh Monica will will'll go
over the ex um Investments thanks Doc
and um so I would just to highlight uh a
few things so I I agree with with chak
enable account is a very powerful
account uh for individuals with
disabilities it just uh um provides the
opportunity to save um funds um and the
earnings grow taxfree if they're used
for qualified disability expenses
including housing which is what is being
um uh studied here as part of this
committee so it is an incredible account
um as as Chuck um mentioned is a game
changer um so so individuals with
abilities are able to save uh they could
use it as a saving account or as a
checking account they could uh receive
uh their paycheck in there uh or it
could be used as a different vehicle
depending on how they want to use it it
could be for uh daily expenses or it
could be even to uh save for retirement
if that's how they want to utilize it
and so the options provided for
Investments are really uh the individual
and the family probably have to think
about what is the purpose of the account
is it to help the individual where daily
daily needs or is it to think about
their future so the Investments need to
really be in line with those thoughts uh
you know with the age of the the individ
idual with the purpose of the savings um
but the options that we provide with the
empal aable plan are are really great
options I mean it really um is um right
now the the plan has um uh seven um type
of uh options strategies it could go
from aggressive again depending on the
the type of objective that the
individual and the family would like to
save or or again conservative so they
can use it for their everyday expens so
uh the option is there the ability to
choose and to design um um something
really powerful for the individual and
the family is is is is definitely there
um and as Chuck mentioned before this is
um you know similar to uh a college SS
account is has been um proven that a
college SS account has helped many many
students and family say for college over
time um and and so this could definitely
do the same thing it could definitely
create um you know wealth and and again
it could do both it could just provide
and assist the individuals and the
families or could you know help them
provide wealth without jaian the
benefits that they receive um so at a
high level again you know right now we
have seven options to invest there will
be uh soon there are plans to add one
more which is this is what we discuss
when we meet with the national a
Alliance uh the 19 States get together
to decide what type of Investments we're
going to have this plan and that is
essentially reviewed on a regular basis
uh so the oversight and the um you know
fedu share responsibility that all of
these states are part of this this
Consortium um you know we really uh
invested in this in this work and in
this account so
um other than that I mean again a high
level is an easy the enabl account is
very easy to open with only
$25 um uh funds can also be rolled over
from if there is an consistent um
fighton account that perhaps was saved
and wasn't fully utilized funds can come
also as a contribution um Chuck
mentioned earlier that the the yearly
contribution is 18 18,000 so that goes
with the gift um um that's that's
related to the tax uh code so for
example in this this year it's 18,000
but next year next year is going to be
19,000 so that is adjusted um uh by the
IRS every year
um so I I think that's um essentially
what I wanted to highlight um there's a
checking account that could be that is
part of this plan um is a definitely an
easy way to also um utilize the funds
once they're in the account um a debit
card is also part of this you know they
have the option to choose for a debit
card or a checking account so it has
again has options flexibility for the
individuals who own these accounts and
um turn it over to you no I think I and
I will tell I just have aate from my
position it truly is a very fortunate
situation that the way the legislature
fashioned able New Hampshire's able
savings you have the treasurer and you
have the executive director working hand
in hand and I will tell you especially
when it comes to the Investments and
Monica her predecessor very invested in
this program um for the State of New
Hampshire because because because the
power for the individual is in it it
truly is uh remarkable I'll also point
out and again what we've seen happen so
in 2026 right now I said age of
Eligibility is 26 that is going up to 46
oh okay in
2026 another big change uh that's known
as the able age adjustment act so I
think it's January of 26 um that's going
to open the door to many individuals um
we see that with um post-traumatic
stress TBI uh things that may actually
uh you know incidences that may happen
after the age of
26 um as Monica had also said um you can
use it as an investment account and you
can use it as an everyday account and
that that's really I would say is the
benefits here um again special needs
trusts have their place um but for an
individual to have a debit card to have
a checking account and to be able to
have that freedom to make his or her own
decision what they're spending the
expenses on um it it truly is remarkable
so that again that's the the NH aable
plan at a very high level I I hope it
helps and we're more than happy to
assist okay are you are you um would you
like to would you be able to take some
questions oh absolutely thank you okay
does do anyone have any questions uh
representative
lontine um what would the advantages
what are the specific advantages to
having an able account versus having a
family member just keep a savings
account for that person
like could you explain that it's a great
question um and I would answer it this
way uh so the benefit of the in if if
you'd like I'll go ahead and we can go
back and forth we I'm just gonna say I
speak that way because
um uh in in our family's case um the my
stepdaughter would not be able to manage
the account on her own but I realize
that many with people with disabilities
of course can right but um how to how to
it work to their advantage yeah it's a
great question so the benefit of open an
enable account is that if the individual
is receiving needs-based
benefits the
SSI and or Medicaid or the housing
benefits When the individual is examined
by those entities to see whether or not
they qualify the money's in the account
are not looked at so that's where the
threshold comes in the $2,000
traditionally anything in and I say this
because I I know that there are so many
people behind me that know this
firsthand when you go over that 2000
family members were had to make a
decision and I will and I'm gonna go one
step further this was not unique to New
Hampshire this was across the country so
it's not I mean I I say that because
what individuals did and we've heard the
stories we'll use a grandmother if a
grandmother was going to give a gift
well maybe you shouldn't or if you do
give the gift we have to spend it that's
the old spend down we have to you know
ensure that it doesn't go into that
bucket that that can be looked at so
that's that if did you want me to go on
if if an individual can't manage the
account um there is what is ref so if
the person um is not legally competent
if there's a guardian involved the
guardian can open the account for and
and manage it for the individual we we
see that in certain situations where the
Office of Public Guardian can open the
account on behalf and and that that
qualifies um and um also if the person
is able to open up the account that
person can name under a POA under the
power of attorney someone who can work
with them to manage manage that account
yeah a followup go ahead yeah I no I
understand that part of it but like some
if someone set up a savings account
specifically for some the individual not
in their name they can like likewise
right um hide that money from from being
held against the individual but I was
wondering what are the other like any
other
specific
um tax or technical
advantages to this account versus just a
a savings account held in someone else's
name yeah so uh regarding the tax that's
definitely a key point and um that is
exactly what I was um mentioning earlier
um if you're able to save money in this
able account the earnings uh will grow
taxfree again if you used the funds for
disability expenses compared to a a
regular savings account the person will
pay taxes um regardless of how they use
the funds but the benefits so two two
huge benefits again it protects the
assets uh can be under the the the
beneficiary name the person with a
disability and also the tax implications
at the feral level are are really
important thank
from go ahead go
ahead um yeah when I first saw the
brochure that um the disability had to
have an onset by age 26 that left leaves
a lot of people out and 46 is much
better um but why have that age limit at
all when you think of all the seniors
who are struggling and perhaps trying to
save
money um that they also risk losing
their benefits I know you didn't write
the initial legislation but what are
your thoughts about that yeah I mean
honestly you know from the from our
perspective if an individual has a
disability you know greater access
greater accessibility and you know
that's why when we saw
the able age adjustment act came about
um it for lack of a better term we knew
that that was huge um you know the
veterans that are coming back yeah um
over 26 and you know I would defer to
monik on this you may know this and
because because we do get the question
how did they come up with 26 at the
federal level um and I think it had like
essentially like a I would assume like a
fiscal note attached to it and they had
to do whatever it had to to get this
thing passed so to speak in 2014 I I I
will probably uh say that I don't know
the details exactly why the the age of
26 but typically the federal government
obviously has to do with the fiscal
impact so they obviously whatever
benefits they're going to provide um
they they're also looking at their
checkbook so I think that's that's part
of the reason so there was a lot of
advocacy to change the law to be able to
increase the age um knowing that you
know how much money was going to cost
the F government for that change so it
has to do with uh how much how much much
taxes all right well um there aren't any
other questions I have a couple um at at
this time how close are you to um
capacity on how many people um could
take advantage of this program how much
room for growth do you
have we have a lot of room for growth um
if we were able to benefit every single
individual and every single family uh in
New Hampshire uh we we should be able to
absolutely definitely that's the hope
and I will tell you consumers and
Advocates and the entire and again I
know it sounds somewhat of a cliche but
we all get it in this room New Hampshire
does do it differently I mean many of
The Advocates that have spoken here that
are in the room today parents they will
get the word out but obviously that
we're always monik and I and our staffs
are always doing the best we can to
ensure that uh individuals know about uh
the NHA plan and we have very robust
social media um we do whatever we can to
get that info out my other question is
um would you feel comfortable about
giving us like an anonymous case study
of how someone used this money to do
something to regarding housing do you um
yeah regarding housing you
know I I'd like to get back to you on
that May um
however I can give you um we we know
that it is head and again this is just
from memory and you know when we were
again when I say we um things have
changed so much over the years when we
when we first launched in 2017 we were
canvas in the state with inperson
meetings um that's changed a bit you
know now that people on understandable
and and they're they're enrolling on
their own and and that's wonderful um
but just when we look at qualified dis
ility expenses Transportation was huge
um for individual we've got that back
individuals who have bought automobiles
um as a result of you know that basic
living expenses because again and I and
I say this I always say this upfront
special needs trusts are very important
um but again it's a trust so there's
going to be from what I understand
there's certain reporting requirements
and as a trustee a little bit different
with able accounts because you're able
to actually get in there and handle it
and spended on that basic living expense
um you know there are individuals who
have bought and I remember this from
being on the road just uh for basic
living expenses if an
individual um if it was an individual at
autism spectrum um disorder that
individual May bought whatever they
needed to ensure that they were
regulated and that could be a a personal
trampoline and I know that the
trampoline in and of itself may seem
small but it was a big deal to the
parents
um any uh technology
education um we've heard those stories
as far as housing we we again just this
is from memory I'm fairly certain that
individuals who had a special need trust
funded the able account and then they
actually paid their rent out of the able
account which again they were able to
pay the check over um to the landlord
but if it's okay chair I can um get back
to and see if we can give you a few case
studies and to to see how they were
actually um utilized that would be that
would be terrific I'd like to include
those in the report um does anyone have
yella feel like this is a little bit
kind of in the weeds and out maybe
outside the scope of
this um the topic that we're covering
but I'm just curious
as you mentioned the difference in
reporting
requirements how if they have a check or
they have a a
a a ATM card how are you guys managing
that that as far as making sure that
it's a qualified expense um are they
having to submit receipts and stuff like
that is because like generally what I'm
thinking of is like FSA accounts you get
a card and you go to the grocery store
and there's a there's specific labels
that say like this will qualify this
won't qualify kind of a thing and it
won't even spend the money if you don't
um but like a check would not have that
requirement or uh and and you have
things on the list like you know a video
game right the the video game
maybe
uh exercise or not how do you how are
you guys termining all of that just
curious I go yeah and and what I can
share is um so uh folks don't have to
submit receipts and it's sort of like a
uh folks are recommended to keep track
of their expenses so in case they're
audited because again this has to do
with um you know in the case of the IRS
you you are subject as a taxpayer uh to
be audited so if by chance you are lucky
enough to be picked that you need to be
able to provide documentation first of
all that you qualify for enable account
and then also that your your expenses
were qualified um so it is recommended
that you keep track the system or the
type of for example if a debit car is
used a lot of times the actual um um
expense will will show up in the record
as um you know the type of expense that
is that you know what the person bought
with that money uh the check checking
account the same um
um so again it really is recommended to
to to keep records uh to to be able to
prove that you you know those those
expenses are uh qualified um expenses uh
the other thing that if by chance a
person um spends money on items are not
qualified um the account owner will be
subject to a 10% penalty and also um um
we'll have to pay the tax for for that
amount of money so it has some
consequences if it's not again it is to
provide the benefits the tax benefit but
um in the event if it's not used for
that purpose there are those you know
that's the consequence to pay the tax on
that money and also a 10%
penalty yeah well
stated um what what we have heard
representative
in we've been at it for a while it's a
legitimate question you're right because
we'll hear that in field what do I do do
I keep the receipts what if I'm hited
yeah I mean at the end of the day you
should um I always equate it to the IRS
as moniker had stated if I say I gave x
amount as a charitable donation keep the
receipt or keep your cancel check or or
whatever so that's that that's a
necessity and we also get questions when
we're presenting um well would this be a
qualified disability expense
well it really is subject Ive um but
again at the national level being part
of the 19 States taking part in National
discussions there has never you know
able Accounts at the federal level and
and at the state level there's an
encouragement to open them what we're
not we're not looking to treat it as a
penalty or a Draconian we're looking we
want this to happen um and I think that
really was the legislative intent and
it's not to downplay what you just said
because you're right I mean at the end
of the day you want to know but we
highly advise the individuals um is the
expense related to the disability that's
number one and does it look to benefit
health and dependence um of the
individual so once you apply it can be
referred to as like a two-prong test
that that can be um you know you have to
look at it I don't you know there are
some that I you know I I use this as an
example an individual with a disability
is going to um a friend's birthday party
and he doesn't drive but he takes an
Uber well the Uber the way I look at it
is a qualified disability expense
related to the disability inur to the
benefit and however the birthday gift
that he is giving to the individual if
it's a cash gift that's that's not going
to fall within the qde but again it's
very subjective we've never again and I
where we where like most state agencies
we're very Hands-On as the legislature
is I have never heard of a story where
an expense was either questioned or
audited and that's a good thing um but
again I think it goes to the I'm hoping
it goes to the legislative intent when
we look back at why we have them but
it's it's a great question because it
it's legitimate I mean I I would want to
know am I going to get audited what do I
expense any other questions
is there anything you'd like to say
before we go on to the next speaker just
like to give a clause no thank you for
the opportunity to to speak about these
accounts uh certainly what I what I
would like to say is um we would like to
do more and promote this program more um
unfortunately our resources are limited
so um we we you know if there is ways
and opportunities uh that we could um uh
contribute to promote this program and
the benefit of this account we'll be
happy to be part of that and
and um and again the work that you're
doing here happy to contribute and and
come back for if you need additional
information happy to do that great thank
you so much thank you so much for the
opportunity representative and members
of this committee um and and it's a you
know it's it's a great committee and
we're glad that we were here and we're
more than happy to assist whichever way
we can terrific thank you so much for
okay um next up I have Susan ssby from
Hampshire good afternoon good afternoon
coming so my name is Sue ssby I'm the
Executive Vice President at Easter Seals
New Hampshire uh where I've worked for
the last 36 years I want to thank you
for the opportunity to speak to you this
afternoon um in my role I'm responsible
for program operations serving over
15,000 children adults seniors and
Veterans uh across New Hampshire many of
those are diagnosed with physical
cognitive or mental health
disabilities housing stability is a
vital social determinant that
contributes to one's overall health and
well-being and access to affordable safe
accessible housing is a common concern
that we hear from those we serve today I
would like to speak specifically um to
highlight the impact that the lack of
housing has on one of the most
vulnerable populations in New Hampshire
individuals with Developmental and
intellectual disabilities for over 35
years Easter Seals has served this
population and we're currently the
largest private provider of
Developmental services in New Hampshire
serving 243 adults on an annual basis
the primary model for providing
residential services to this population
is a shared Living Model where agency
uh contract with an individual couple or
family to provide Room and Board and
Care to an individual in a private home
in the contractor's home while this
model has worked out beautifully for so
many people some people living their
lifetime with with the contracted family
for others um it hasn't worked out as
well um it has led to homelessness
emergency placement and unnecessary
hospitalizations Easter Seals currently
serves 90 people and share living homes
and in looking at our average placements
about 5.2 years so on average people are
moving every 5 years families are
looking for a choice in the model of of
Residential Service delivery um they
want a model that offers more permanent
housing one that you can stay in the
same community and age in
place in an effort to increase housing
options for this population there are
groups of families all over the state
I've met with several of them there's
also a a developer who are really
working to create permanent um Housing
Solutions they have to raise money
privately um taking years to get the
money to secure the property to renovate
the property also dealing with some
regulatory barri barriers um meanwhile
aging families are struggling to provide
care to their loved ones and individuals
have limited options for residential
services
uh in addition Easter Seals it it sorry
it should just not be this hard for
families to find permanent Housing
Solutions for their loved ones in
addition Easter Seals uh operates 21
staffed residential um programs with 57
beds for individuals with intellectual
and developmental disabilities who
experience High needs in the areas of um
behavioral regulation and medical needs
uh these homes are smaller in nature
typically one to four beds uh to ensure
high quality care and successful
integration into the community these
homes provide stable housing 247
Staffing Clinical Services
Transportation recreational employment
opportunities services are built through
the Medicaid waiver um and housing
expenses room and board expenses are not
allowable expenses individuals living in
these programs uh receive Social
Security benefits in the amount of 824
per month which needs to cover all
housing expenses food utilities
maintenance
utilities we typically budget about $350
a month for food uh which leaves about
$474 a month uh for to pay for the rest
of the rest of the bill the housing
expenses which as you can imagine
doesn't cover it um Market rents have
reached an alltime high in New Hampshire
um we we are experiencing rents for a
three-bedroom property from 2700 to
$3,000 a month uh for a property that's
suitable um while the reimbursement from
the individuals is $1,400 for all
expenses the Bureau of Developmental
services does have access to State
funding to bridge the funding Gap
however there's not sufficient funding
at this time that funding is not
available to every person in this model
of care and there's a wait list for
anyone new it's just not a sustainable
business model for private providers and
as a result many providers have stopped
providing this level of care our
inability to support New Hampshire
providers to develop and maintain
housing has led to costly out ofate
placements currently East um New
Hampshire has approximately 50
individuals in out ofate placements a
scenario which is not only expensive but
very difficult on the individuals and
their
families recently um there was a round
of arpa funding that has provided
startup resources for some private
providers to develop new residential
options in New Hampshire which is
amazing
however the long-term fiscal
sustainability for the housing isn't
clear I urge a study um committee to
examine um and review potential funding
streams and regul Regulatory barriers to
ensure that all New Hampshire residents
especially those with the greatest needs
have access to Affordable permanent
housing in their home state of New
Hampshire thank you thank you does
anyone have
questions representative yella first and
um maybe there I'm just trying to get
some clarification on some of those
numbers that you were throwing out um
[Music]
non for services yeah for non Housing
Services um and then you said
$1,400 correct so and and so I'm
wondering if that 1400 where that where
that $1,400 is coming that is that from
the people so basically that there's an
824 standard of need it's called um and
so when you back out the food of 350 a
month from the 824 it leaves like
$474 per person times three yeah times
three is the 1400 rough times three
three most of the it was based on a
three person home sorry okay so
you're okay sorry
so okay so you're you giving me the
number the amount of
money you you also in your statement
said that you're housing between one and
four people correct in a room or
in a in a house I mean t typically there
are three three bedrooms typically so
there are some some programs where
there's one person um that's staff 247
but typically we we have three bedroom
homes okay so and can I can ahead thanks
um so I'm trying to a little bit
understand how your program works so
it's it's you're you're renting a house
house mhm and then you are asking for
applications for people that want to
come live in the house and then you uh
you would be offering services to all of
the people that are part of that house
um and that would be kind of like the
facility corre and and then you rinse
and repeat you do that again and again
like yeah these are Community Based long
term supports and services homes
typically three bedrooms correct we are
in rental properties across the state
we're three individuals who have common
support needs or living together and we
provide services built to the Medicaid
waiver and then where we're struggling
is just the r and board and housing
increased okay and so you said that
there's a um
247 uh services and so that made me
think of like you have someone there
247 or you have like houses around like
a common structure where they could go
service people 247 so how does the 247
so these are homes um that are in the
community um and the house is like
staffed with shift staff in in a
specific house located in the community
um and and the individuals are accessing
their community so each home is a unique
program it's not a campus um they're
they're living in their home
communities okay so the the people that
are all living in the
[Music]
same same uh
structure um are you trying to get them
with similar needs so that they can H
utilize the same Personnel or you have
multiple like one Personnel per person
247 no it's not 101 247 the support
needs are really designed based on you
know someone's individual service plan
yeah um and typically they shared staff
like there might be one staff overnight
um for the three individuals typically
the service needs are are similar um so
either people might have like you know a
lot of um medical needs and need for you
know accessible housing maybe increased
nursing um and it's shared Staffing okay
and it's based on the service plan in
there and their need their individual
needs and you have um
n 90 people so we have 90 people in our
in our shared living homes which is the
foster care foster care like adult
foster care
homes okay um so that's a different
different category than this one this
this one how many homes you have we have
21 certified residents right right okay
I write that down 25 with 50 B with 57
BS that's this not okay y thank you very
much sorry just it's complicated we're
it is
complicated representative L you had a
question yeah I'm trying to I'm trying
to understand it all too um but how does
it made sense to me I'm sorry
that the residential service
programs how do they differ from what we
used to know as the group
home um and did Easter Seals have group
homes um we we didn't start out having
resid uh group homes back in the day we
we were later to the residential service
Market um I think what's changed over
time is really the size of the home as
well as like the involvement in the
community um and and making sure that
the the services provided are really
promoting
inclusion uh employment um and being
belonging in the in the community I
time I guess my question is
um well we had an incident in Manchester
over the summer where there was um an
individual living in a a placement
similar to this and he kept leaving the
building and um the neighbor you know
showing up in the neighbor's yards and
they didn't know him and they you know
his behaviors were um they felt
threatened by him so do you get a lot of
push back um in the neighborhoods where
you're trying to place these individuals
and um you this is a great question and
sadly yes um we haven't opened a new
home for a while but um often you know
it it's it's scary for Neighbors because
they don't know what they don't know um
you know we take great care in citing
and where we where we have these homes
so while we are in the community we
really think about the neighbors the
neighbor relations and you know how to
promote people in like valued social
roles but there definitely still is some
concern with Neighbors in terms of you
know um not having these types of homes
in their neighborhood I also think you
know you need to take great care in
screening um the clinical needs of of
the of the residents and ensuring that
um you have the Staffing support the
clinical backup the clinical support and
the backup to respond um to
appropriately to behavioral situations
that might
arise okay I guess the other question
that I would ask is that um my
assumption is that you're using existing
buildings for these um um for these uh
placements for folks do you find that um
there are barriers um for the kinds of
care that individuals with disabilities
might need because of the fact that
you're using existing buildings um yes
so we we're in rental properties for
most of most of the the homes that we
have um and I think when it comes to
accessibility that's the biggest barrier
we see so for folks who need fully
accessible shower
um you know lifts um ceiling lifts um
there are not a lot of rental properties
that accommodate those those folks um
needs um and just just to follow up you
you mostly have rental properties is
that because um purchasing is properties
is too expensive or it
creates um certain complications that
make it harder for you to deliver
services
yeah we we um it I mean the housing
market is really expensive right now um
and it has been so we have chosen to
rent Overby just due to the
cost and the funding streams to cover
you know all of the when you own a house
the repairs and and the ongoing upkeep
it's just really not a lot of funding to
cover
um
so for I'm very surprised that you rent
um because
that makes me think that you know as as
the um the rents rise and and
be it leaves you open to not being able
to have those 21 facilities right um
especially when like the you know the
landlord no longer wants to to uh
continue the renew a lease or something
like that right there it seems like
there's
um a lot
of
variability in that
model um do are you a aware of anyone
any other groups that do a similar model
that purchase or are are are you pretty
much the only one there are and in this
recent round of arpa funding um which
was specifically designed for new beds
we were approved to purchase one of our
homes so we are purchasing one home um
we're also renovating another home that
we we own so we are moving to more of a
um owned model um for that very
reason yes it seems like fixed cost like
being able to have a 30-year mortgage or
whatever like that you could have
certain amount of no you know obviously
the repairs would be variable but the uh
the rent essentially could be foren in a
uh longer range um have you had to close
any places because of increased rent
kind of priced you out of the $1,400
that you I we've been subsidizing it um
you know and the bureau has worked hard
to you know um to access the state funds
so to help bridge that so that's that's
helped us um we have not closed any due
to that um but we are evaluating our our
ability to continue to provide that
level of care um so and that's where the
ownership is starting to like the you
know especially when we got the arpa
funds to be able to purchase um you know
the property that we have in in we New
greatly um I would like to follow up
again if you're
fine okay um
the I also have
some
some questions about
the uh you said that the neighbors as
far as not not being happy that you're
going to move in or something but it it
would still be a residential building
and the building is already existing
right so how do the Neighbors come
involved at all right you're you're just
renting a building from someone and then
there's essentially like three roommates
living in a building so how do the
neighbors have an impact on you so
sometimes the neighbors will um
hear about us about who's moving in I'm
not sure how um and you know once we're
there there's three shifts a day so it's
a little different than other you know
their neighbors um people might see
individuals with disabilities and draw
conclusions um so and then at times
we've gone to different towns when we've
opened it just be good partners to say
we're opening up um and sometimes that
has opened up um you know some issues
Y and those can you specify those issues
did they do they want to um Zone it like
like say that you have to be in a
commercial property or something like
that or how how are they creating
barriers um so when I this is a while
ago but yes we had some issues with
people saying oh no this is not this is
not residential this is a business you
know this is and you know we're
but we're we're not we push back it's a
residential program three individual
three unrelated individuals live there
and eventually we we get you know we get
through but it it just isn't always the
experience okay does anyone have any
other
questions go right ahead I think this um
based on your model it seems like you're
um not required to be licensed in each
of these you're essentially utilizing
the uh the certification model of the
[Music]
um the lure requirements of this of New
Hampshire so we do have two properties
that are licensed if it's over three
beds it needs to it needs to be
licensed so if there's over three beds
it has to be licensed so we have two
programs is that is that because you
told them that you could potentially
have a fourth person or because there's
literally like four bedrooms and even if
you only kept three people in there all
the time then it would not be considered
it if we had three people there it would
be certified but we have four
individuals living there okay so and
those are homes that are specially
designed for people who need full
accessibility um and there's four four
bedrooms you know full um Rule and
shower and lifts in the ceilings and you
know everything that they need to live
you um yeah so if I could just follow up
on yeah this line of questioning um
these you've created a a facility for
four people um that it sounds like it
was probably pretty expensive to make
sure you could have the lifts and the
bathrooms an additional expense and so
forth um what was the limiting factor to
four people because you know potentially
maybe you could have six people living
in a facility where you've invested so
much in um I mean this is a a
residential home so there like that was
repurposed the landlord actually did all
of the renovations um so there just
wasn't six bedrooms
okay but the um the fact that you could
put in
a an extra person in there made the um
made the finances work out better
because you were getting income from
another person or I mean the finances
don't really work out but um but I mean
I think it helps with you know the
Staffing Resources on the service
side and again it's just those beds that
can can support individuals who need
fully accessible housing is they're
rare this is thank you so much for
coming this is very interesting so so um
I assume that the four
um four
bedroom place that you've now have
licensed and all of this this um work
installed you're you're renting we are
and
um
how how do
you
decide uh you know that that you're
going to try and invest that time and
money in such a in a situation like like
that rental like how do you make that
choice and is that is that something
is is difficult or made harder because
it's renting um or do you guys kind of
like the the landlord invested a bunch
into it also so you guys are kind of uh
tied together at the hip in those ca in
this case uh the two cases the landlord
um received some grant funding to to
renovate the property um for us to build
or buy something equivalent would it
would be cost prohibit
okay interesting thank
you okay well thank you so much for
coming you're welcome um this was very
informative um I have your email address
so you know if we have any further
questions um I I may reach out to you
again absolutely and uh thank you again
you all right next up on the agenda is
um housing action New
Hampshire just come on up and state your
name
and Madam chair members of the study
committee for the record my name is
Alyssa marglin I serve as director of
housing action New Hampshire thank you
for your work on this committee I was at
your inaugural meeting and have caught
up on um the other presentations that
you've had what I thought I would do for
you today is um talk with you about
policy proposals that have made their
way way through the legislature and
things that are likely on the horizon as
you consider um what your study
committee um might recommend to the
legislature moving
forward um I know that you uh dug deep
into the challenges of rental subsidies
um you had a really uh robust
conversation with New Hampshire housing
about the housing Choice Voucher Program
you learned about the long waiting lists
uh about um um some of the priorities
put on those waiting lists um uh and I
know Senator rardy was a gas to learn
that you get a preference if you have um
uh a a fatal Illness but you're likely
to wait for two years um and I guess I
have um some thoughts about that
conversation that you had on the
committee I'll share that I think at the
federal level on the ADV see that we do
um with our Congressional Delegation and
our Congressional Delegation is all have
proven um to be very interested in
trying to come up with solutions to our
housing crisis and have weighed in
everywhere they they can but I will say
more broadly one of the
challenges uh is that um rental
subsidies make up over 90% of Hud's
budget now and that is creating just
budgetary overall budgetary challenges
and um undermining the likelihood that
they will add additional vouchers so I I
don't think that we will see a real push
to increase vouchers that come to the
states through Housing and Urban
Development I do think that there is
some momentum around um bringing back in
some form the emergency rental
assistance program that we had during
arpa and obviously it'll depend on the
direction of the next Administration but
that proved a really important tool to
many states and there there is some
momentum there um what I I do want to
contemplate though is um other state
Solutions around Bridges to Section 8
and um I think um you heard the success
of the housing Bridge subsidy program
for people with severe and persistent
mental illness um and that resulted
um uh in the settle Olstead settlement
um uh during the Obama Administration
with the state of New Hampshire that
does create a subsidy for that
population and they work closely with
New Hampshire Housing and I think um Mr
mlen told you about the 811 program um
so essentially a a state uh temporary
subsidy until you access uh until you're
able bble to work through the the
waiting list on Section 8 so something
something to consider there I want to
speak again about the need for more
advocacy um to the Department of Health
and Human Services to finally finally
operationalize the new Supportive
Housing Medicaid benefit the legislature
directed the Department of Health and
Human Services to apply for this um
state plan amendment in
2019 um CMS approved the Supportive
Housing Medicaid benefit in 2022 and we
are still waiting for the Department to
operationalize this this would cover
Supportive Housing Services for um uh
AOC accessing housing and um and also uh
to uh Ser ongoing Services needed to
sustain housing um the department did
announce the credentialing opportunity
to providers in the summer of this year
but um it is being held up again um so I
think uh more advocacy from the
legislature directed to the department
to operationalize this benefit is is
needed at this
time finally I I'll jump to the capital
subsidies um again you learned a lot
from Mr mclen and learning about how
below market rate capital is attractive
to developers and that those developers
pass on those savings they're getting by
not going in traditional debt into
affordability and that they are often
partnered with either housing Choice
voucher acceptance or Project based
vouchers what I want to um uh advocate
for is increasing the overall um
resource to the affordable housing fund
think you've seen this in a lot of um
the candidates plans uh who are running
for governor um and uh I do want to
caution against designating funding to a
certain population and I say this from
experience um one of the first
Appropriations I secured as a uh new
director at housing action New Hampshire
was designated to people recovering from
opioid dis disorders and it proved very
difficult um uh developer to to
disseminate and allocate
uh it was after that that we started to
advocate for flexibility in the fund um
developers who serve certain populations
are very motivated to serve that
population generally and um I I think
we've learned that um allowing those
developers to respond to Market needs
population needs in a larger more
flexible fund is a better policy
solution than chopping it up and saying
this is for the this population and that
population
um so uh with that I'll I'll say that we
have been um advocating for a change in
the real estate transfer tracks car out
formula that goes to the affordable
housing fund uh we'd think that $5
million per year is is really uh
insufficient given the crisis um and
would like to see that formula changed
in the N budget cycle to at least um two
times the the current
formula and last year when this was
proposed although it was an off budget
year um it did have a by partisan
support and it did have support of the
New Hampshire realtors in addition to
housing action New
Hampshire um I want to also bring up
some other state level these are more
lwh hanging fruit
opportunities um I think it's come up
the expansion of 79e and what that could
provide so we have um uh you know had
successful legislation last year to
expand this uh uh enable municipalities
to offer this benefit um and so I think
that uh there could be a willingness to
work with that
tool um and I also think that the
Council on housing stability is an
interesting entity to look at um that
has really heightened coordination among
state agencies and advocates for for
different
populations and I think it would be
helpful to have a member of the
disability Community one or two members
added to the Council on housing
stability Council and housing stability
was created by executive order by
Governor cuno at the start of the
pandemic but the legislature codified it
um and so it could be amended uh now in
statute to add uh additional members to
the
council um I also want to name another
recent um
uh legislative success and that is the
launch of the housing Champion program
and I believe representative yella you
sat on the advisory committee for that
program that program was recently
launched like maybe two weeks ago by
business and economic Affairs and
announced to municipalities and then um
will provide um incentives for
infrastructure dollars through uh
designation and recognition as a housing
Champion community and there may be an
opportunity to work with the office of
uh Planning and Development to add
criteria
around accessible um design and and
other issues um to integrate the needs
of uh housing for people with
program um finally I want to talk about
the need for the state to set more
reasonable standards at the local level
we're often um when we discuss um
proposals like uh improving New
Hampshire's accessory dwelling unit law
or allowing single family Property
Owners to turn their um single family
into a duplex Triplex or fourplex we're
often um find ourselves in a uh age-old
policy debate about local control versus
State mandates and I don't think it
needs to be an either or but I do think
that the state could say when some when
local municipalities have over regulated
to the point where they're forcing their
own members of their Community to leave
and so in some cases when a property
owner wants to create an accessory
dwelling unit for their child with
disabilities they should be allowed to
do that by right if a property owner
wants to create a duplex or Triplex
because they want um Support Services in
their home they should be allowed to do
so by right and the state has the
ability to set that reasonable standard
for our
localities um and so um I think you'll
likely see um proposals they're already
lsrs for next year around um accessory
dwelling unit log in um and uh I know
parking came up at a recent hearing here
and indeed um you know uh representative
yella hb400 a bill that you sponsored
does do just that where the state says a
more reasonable parking standard for
municipalities is one and a half spaces
for multif family 10 units or more but
also for studios and
one-bedrooms that meet the standards of
the workforce housing law so some
progress and and something to to build
on
there and with that I think I'll
conclude and just take your
[Music]
questions have questions um I I have I
have one um I am a huge fan of the the
every other Friday calls that New
Hampshire housing does and um one of the
people that you had on was Carmen
lorence from
lonia and she was talking about how they
were trying to build a Supportive
Housing structure in lonia on a lot and
the problem was now this was Supportive
Housing so I'm assuming that you know
these
people Pro many of them didn't drive but
they couldn't make the project pencil
with the amount of parking that the city
was
requiring um to build this facility so
um how often does that happen um so
first of all representative thank you
for the shout out for housing action New
Hampshire's housing matter zooms um and
uh thank you for participating in those
um I think that's why you saw us push so
hard on hp400
um last year uh and uh if I recall the
committee of conference conversation was
actually representative Sweeney who
noted um that he wakes up to that he
rents in Salem and that he wakes up to
empty parking spots um where he rents uh
every day and that frustrated him
because that could be that that
infrastructure that developable land um
would be a a good place for more housing
or or business and that requiring you
know this this Paving um in a formula
that doesn't align with the community
needs didn't make sense so I think the
state in that case you know um sets some
more reasonable standard um it also in
hb400 also requires that municipalities
accept alternative Parking Solutions so
you've you've been talking with families
um and with with tenants uh you know
part of our our Rental Community rental
population here who doesn't drive so why
are we requiring that they have two
parking spots per bedroom um that
doesn't make sense so for some cases now
municipalities must accept solutions
they can challenge um that solution if
they don't think it meets needs but now
uh you've opened that door uh through
State policy um and I was thinking I
know representa St we' talked about
bringing um some developers to your
committee and so um Lakes Region
Community developers was one that I was
thinking of uh bringing forward I know
you had um a member of their board here
uh recently um who also works for Late
swegan Community Services Yeah well yeah
this is our this is our our final um
meeting before we have to do our um your
initial report right but you're doing
continue right we will be continuing on
for a year we would certainly love to
hear from um developers about the
challenges that they are facing um
anyone have any
yella thank you for
uh uh your work on um 1400 and and the
um the housing
Champion
um project
the I believe in
the uh housing Champion rules I mean at
least there was the discussion about um
uh kind of mixed mixed use
um
housing or like housing with businesses
in um kind of in the same area or
vicinity or even in the same building
um and and I don't know if it became
part of the rules or not um whether they
get points for for having that but it
seems from my perspective in the
testimony that we've heard in this which
obviously came later than the rule
setting um it seems like
the the access to the
by the people with
disabilities could be a barrier to
getting getting them kind of out in the
community or getting them even to be
kind of independent at all um
and I'm wondering if
you that was one of the things that kind
of like jumped out to me as as in the
last few weeks I'm um wondering if um
you had any thoughts
or
uh insights about
um like kind of that those mixed uh use
they like the past legislation on it and
and if housing Champion if you know
offand CH housing Champion did anything
uh trying to encourage
that um so thank you for the question
and thank you for your participation in
the housing Champion Advisory Board um I
know the rules passed Jael car this
summer but I I uh I haven't looked at
them in a while so I'd have to look and
get back to you representative um I do
think that um
another um reason that the affordable
housing fund is so important to our
state is it allows for that creativity
so a lot of a lot of federal money comes
with restrictions on and you you learned
a lot about that um but the having um in
the capital stack that kind of flexible
resource um so if you want to do
something like mixed use or if you want
part of it to be market rate um uh you
can you can do that with the affordable
housing fund uh and um you know New
Hampshire's had a state Housing Trust
Fund since 1988 but it's only in the
last couple of budget cycles that we
actually started putting any money in it
at all the formula for the real estate
transfer tax carve out is quite new um
and I think um we've learned how
valuable it is as we've gotten deeper
and deeper into the crisis but the
formula hasn't changed um and so uh I
think that that um is just another
argument for that but I don't know I
would have to look on the housing
Champions to see and I hear what you're
saying in terms of um you wouldn't want
to put some broad criteria in places
where it wouldn't make sense because the
population needs so I would need to look
you would need to look at the um at how
the program is being rolled out but I I
name it as the state is making
investments in these in this direction
to deal with a housing crisis so let's
make sure that the interests of these
populations are at the table and being
Solutions go ahead um yeah I I think
that kind of like the walkability and
and and also being able to have you know
services that that are provided to you
look close to you um is is important you
know we talk we've talked many times
about the people that don't drive in
here and and stuff like that um be just
being able to kind of get out and into
the community um that can be a barrier
with kind of the zoning like all all the
business over here and your your
residential stuff is over here
um but I wanted to kind of touch on what
we talked about or what we were hearing
a little bit earlier um about how people
the the business was renting these um
these homes to provide services to the
community um
and it also seems like you know there's
a capital kind of cost that was a
barrier for
getting uh purchasing of these
facilities is there
anything
that um new hampsh housing that jumped
out to you in that conversation I guess
that that New Hampshire housing could
currently do um to help secure funding
or to to provide interest you
know free loans or whatever um or is um
that something
that is possible to be done through New
Hampshire housing if if it
if it needs a new program to to be able
to meet that need or or is there
something that that can do that now okay
I do want to note that you know Easter
Seals is probably one of the most
successful providers in our state for
this population and um most sustainable
model so I I trust if they've decided to
have a rental model or ownership model
that they're making good fiscal
decisions given how they've grown and
served the most uh people in our state
and I also know that you know the
leadership there is very familiar with
the capital and sub rental subsidy tools
available through our state Housing
Finance Agency because they've done work
with that agency but also to clarify for
this committee We Are The Advocates
housing action New Hampshire and so
we're not the we I'm not employed by New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority so I
don't want to speak to what their
programs could do I do want to name that
the um special I'm going to get the
title wrong Commission on um opioid
settlements um has designated a a fund
specifically for Supportive Housing for
um people with uh opioid and substance
use disorders again and that they are
launching a separate initiative there
and I um I would ask New Hampshire
housing to name it I believe it's $6
million for three years and could renew
um as part of a the opioid settlement
that came to the state and uh so to
answer your question I think there are
tools that you could create but I would
caution against creating them within the
trust fund because you don't want to
start once you start doing that it's
like hard to um return to flexibility
but I do think you could have special
initiatives for specific population
but I would defer to our colleagues that
uh who um create those kind of financial
projects
L could you explain a little more what
um are the
79e programs in
municipalities yes so 79e exists in
statute right it's and and the state
simply enabled it to expand it um in
1400 it expanded 79e to be used for
commercial conversions but essentially
it would be up to the municipality to
offer that
um and I think in the community toolbox
bill that we passed in 2017 I believe
was the first time we directed we
started to look at 79 as a tool uh that
allowed for municipalities to do it just
to incentivize Workforce housing but
then we expanded it to say if you want
you could also incentivize a
developer um through tax deferral on uh
well any more questions
okay thank you all right thank you so
coming all right we have one more person
on the agenda and that would be Lori
us and then um we we'll have to look
over the minutes and accept
those does he
thank
you my name is Lori McIntosh and I'm
with our place NH a few weeks ago I made
a statement in this room that I would
like to retract I apologize to the
committee and in particular to senator
richardi for criticizing a new project
that would house adults with
developmental
disabilities I did something that I'm
famous for and that's opening my mouth
before activating my
brain um we need all kinds of housing
models and choices for people with
disabilities what might be right for one
person is not necessarily right for
someone else I cannot disparage a
well-run group home model in fact there
is a wonderful Group Home in Portsmouth
that I'm well familiar with where the
residents are extremely happy and
thriving and I'm sure the Easter Seals
group homes are great too so to set the
record straight I'm glad that Senator
richardi was able to help obtain funding
for that project and any effort to
provide more housing for this population
should be applauded and not
criticized what I was trying to say was
that in our excitement to create more
housing options we need to be careful to
make sure we learn from the lessons of
the past we need to make sure that all
housing opportunities provide adequate
support encourage integration in the
Greater Community assist with jobs and
recreational activities and promote
self-determination people need to be
able to make their own choices about
where they live how much help they need
and how they spend their time thank you
for allowing me to try to set the record
straight okay thank you so much all
right okay so um we're gonna um review
the minutes from the last meeting and um
just you know talk among yourselves and
then we'll have to accept the
sorry okay I don't want to interrupt
what you're reading now though so okay
yeah let let let let's if you would give
us a few minutes to do this you can just
sit there and review your notes and then
yeah I spent hours listening to the
testimony to understand what was said
wow lots of typos probably done the most
seen
Transit may I think he just
how yes I just thought that it was Manch
Transit Authority right and they have
of
e
okay all right so you can have a motion
to accept
amendment I I motion to accept the
Amendments as we uh explain the
Amendments okay to the second for that
the to the clerk second my own all right
I will second it and then
umor yep say I we we'll accept the
minutes okay now we have a couple more
people who would like to speak um if you
could uh state your name and spell it if
you if it's
hard hopefully not uh my name is Marissa
Berg
beerg and I am executive director at
Community Support Network we are the
trade Association for the 10 area
agencies in the state of New Hampshire
um I just wanted to my my testimony is
is short I recognize we're coming in at
the end um I just want to thank you all
for your time and and really working to
try and understand this
uh really sort of vast um issue that
really touches a lot of people um and
the um I'm excited that there's a
continuation um over the next year so
thank you for that um you've heard a lot
of testimony surrounding uh housing
considerations and uh particularly
surrounding um issues relating to people
with developmental disabilities and I
just wanted to to sort of close out um
as you're going into preparing the
interim report um with a few asks for
the next session session um and as you
are reviewing housing related bills uh
over these next few months please keep
in mind what you've learned from all the
testimony that's been provided um if a
developer is providing information
around housing um are the homes
accessible to all through Universal
Design do they Foster the particip I
ation of all residents in the community
can people with disabilities afford to
live there um you've heard stakeholders
that are sharing um how complex the
regulations are that surround
certification and licensing uh
certification and issues issues and
confusion about requirements are often
really challenging to navigate and are
adding barriers to development um on top
of what exists around funding and and
other issues around own resources please
consider that licensing and Licensing
and certification changes
um that could potentially surmount some
of these logistical challenges while
also still keeping guard rails in place
to protect the community for the long
term please also consider the importance
of adus and especially adus that have
enough square
footage for uh an individual to to also
live with a live-in caregiver um adus
allow adults with disabilities to have
their own space to live while still
being able to access support when needed
they can also help fill a gap in housing
availability for people with
disabilities the proposed budget from
BDS um as we know it for right now
contains an increase in funding to fund
room and board These funds are needed to
help cover the costs of housing for
individuals with developmental
disabilities were unable to maintain
sufficient employment to cover costs
Medicaid funds cannot be used for this
purpose which leaves a gap for
individuals with significant support
needs related to their
disability we ask that you support this
request for the coming SE session it is
critically important that the committee
recognized that there's no one-size
fits-all solution for housing for
individuals with disabilities everyone
has unique needs and circumstances that
impact what housing Arrangement is
appropriate for them individ uals must
retain the ability to live in the home
setting that works best for their needs
staffed residential homes enhanced
Family Care Homes supported Independent
Living independent housing within the
community and others and we have to make
sure to always remember that we are not
returning to a world where individuals
with developmental disabilities lived in
institutions also any choice in housing
and any discussion um
we need to have it shared in plain
language for people with disabilities to
be able to access so I just wanted to
leave those uh sort of closing remarks
um From csn's perspective um and again
we look forward to continuing to hear
more about what others in the community
are
sharing all right thank you does anyone
questions representative
lonte I just want to clarify a little
bit
um about the budget funding for from
BDS for the um the 10 Community um area
agencies I'm sorry um so um the area
agencies um what are the types of
housing um options do you provide again
I'm familiar only with the the home um
support program no what is it called I
know I can't remember pdms um a home
providership okay but could you just
elaborate on the different options that
your the agencies provide so are you um
are you asking about the list of the
different options that I just listed or
what area agencies provide what area
agencies provide your the agencies yeah
so area agencies um are the the
designation of Area Agency is a uh
specific sort of type of service um
within area agencies though they can
choose to provide certain other provider
services so Direct Services um there are
some not all area agencies that choose
to provide Residential
Services um CPS Services which are we
sort of historically referred to his day
Services um for residential services um
an area agency can choose to offer um
enhanced family care which has been kind
of the adult foster care model um where
an individual would live with a
contracted home provider um so that's
enhanced Family Care um there are some
uh area agencies who operate a staffed
residence so it could be a 247 staffed
model um sort of similar to what you
heard Sue talking a little bit about
today um there are there's also a um
varying levels of community support for
individuals who live in the community so
there are some people who really just
need some help getting groceries or
getting out into the community getting
to work um and that you know that that's
really dependent on the individual's
needs um there's also um other support
models um where you know an individual
might live with a family um a family
caregiver um you know it really sort of
runs the gamut there are many many
different uh housing options for
individuals and some area agencies
choose to do
some um you know it really is a it's a
elaborating anything
else thank you for coming thank you very
much we'll see you again
thanks okay is there anybody else with
anything like to add anything else
before we
name thank you very much I will be quick
I know everyone wants to
end this so that they can carry on with
their day um my name is Vanessa blae and
I serve as the Director of policy and
planning for the New Hampshire Council
on developmental disabilities and I was
asked by three um people who have the
experience of disability to read um into
the record their testimony um because
they could not be able to attend
today the first um testimony that I'm
going to read is by someone by the name
of em Emory Quinn of Manchester New
Hampshire my name is Emory Quinn and I
am one of your disabled constituents I
am currently living in Barnstead at a
family home due to the inaccessibility
of my current apartment in Manchester
which I am to trying to break the lease
of I am living on the second floor of my
apartment building the elevator in the
building was broken down for over a week
which is the second time there has been
problems with it the inspection for
which has been expired for over 6 months
at this point with the elevator down the
water has been shut off multiple times
during construction with a note posted
to the doors instructing residents to
use facilities that are a quarter mile
away from the building following a road
with crumbling sidewalks and no curb
Cuts while expressing my concern not
just for myself but for the other
wheelchair users in this building and
those dependent on the elevator I was
told to mind my own business
since we have moved in there have been
two long bouts of construction during
that time the accessible ramp has been
blocked off and the accessible parking
places have been filled with equipment
thankfully the construction Crews have
been helpful in dealing with it the
management have not been helpful even
with multiple reminders we have been
consistently met with indifference and
hostility we signed the lease knowing we
had one small closet to place my
wheelchair and other Mobility AIDS in at
this time it is currently being replaced
with a washer and dryer leaving us with
the task of finding storage elsewhere
most months we can hardly afford food
and rent let alone the idea of renting a
storage
facility this has added to the complete
inaccessibility of my current apartment
as I am left with very little mobility
and means of getting around during the
current construction the floor has been
torn up in the hallways leaving it un
even and very risky to wheel my chair
over entrances are blocked and the
accessible parking spaces are again
filled with pallets I am afraid of
rolling into the building because of the
possible damage to my wheelchair which I
would be left paying $5,000 out of
pocket
for during all of this I keep reflecting
on the privilege I have that many that
find themselves in my situation do not a
place to stay knowledge of resources
time to reach out and learn about what
can be done to help and connections to
community
organizations many people don't have
families to stay with or other options
to fall back on I am incredibly grateful
for the resources and support that I do
have but even still I find myself in
what feels like an impossible
situation I can only imagine what it
would be like without the help I do have
how others in my situation feel when
they have no support or help at
all I have spent over the last month
reaching out out to several legal
departments and organizations that are
there for times like this specifically
for lowincome and disabled individuals
but because of the housing crisis
everyone is at Max Capacity and unable
to provide Aid I reached out to the
governor's Commission on disability and
learned that they would not be able to
pursue my case without attaching my name
to it not being able to access even
basic help without the protection of an
anonity sorry is a huge deterrent as
there is so much risk involved
retaliation is illegal but we also know
that it happens myself and many others
in this position barely have enough
money to afford rent let alone what it
may cost to defend ourselves against
possible retaliation from landlords or
the ability to take our landlords to
court there's even more risk involved if
you are an immigrant if you are a person
of color if you are queer or disabled
intersecting identity increase the risk
and fear of retaliation exponentially it
is a risk that a lot of people cannot
afford to
take I want to thank you for your time
and dedication to looking into such an
important issue that many gr Granite
Staters find themselves faced with as a
disabled person we're often invisible
and not given the space to speak out
about issues that affect us directly
it's refresh refreshing to see that
these spaces are being created and that
there are people out there are willing
to listen and try to take action to
situation the next one is from Caitlyn
Fulton a citizen of Dober New
Hampshire my name is Caitlyn Fulton and
I am a citizen of Dober New Hampshire I
am also disabled my disabilities affect
what kind of housing I can access
literally stairs especially those
featured in the many beautiful old homes
the Sea Coast boasts are complete
non-starters for me I finally found a
brand new mostly Ada accessible
apartment here in do but it costs me
over half of my take-home pay I am
blessed that my parents were willing to
co-sign my lease but I work full-time
for a state agency I'm 36 years old I
should not need to have my parents coign
the first accessible Housing Opportunity
I have found in my adult life how many
of my disabled brothers and sisters do
not have the support or means to afford
an apartment made with access in mind
that allow them to live fully
independently in the
community I believe a few paths are in
front of us in New Hampshire to create
more accessible housing fund
Rehabilitation projects to retrofit
existing apartment buildings up to Ada
code enforce accessibility requirements
in new housing
construction expand funding for Section
8 housing vouchers lessen the wait times
incentivize more landlords to to accept
those vouchers I appreciate your time
manner and lastly this one is from Kelly
aart of Nashua New
Hampshire my name is Kelly aart and I
live in Nashua I am asking you to
consider the following information in
your review of how the housing crisis in
New Hampshire impacts people with
disabilities I feel the disabled should
not live in an Institutional setting we
should be able to interact with other
people people with and without
disabilities I live in an apartment
building I have a Section 8 housing
Choice voucher I work as an independent
consultant and I cannot afford the
$1,900 a month rent for a
one-bedroom I go to yoga in Kong and the
library in my community the public needs
to see that people with disabilities are
like anywhere else and learn to accept
us thank you very much and I will
provide the written testimony thank you
anybody
you um if there's nothing um further um
adjourn can we can I didn't you want to
ask yeah I'm um so at the end of last
um last
time there was a question of like how
the the interim report is going to be
written and what's going to be on it and
how how are we gonna write write it and
what's going to be on it and stuff like
that so um did you you said that you
were going to get some information about
that right did you get some and can you
share with me okay here um um here um
our researcher gave us a um template for
what our report could look like um she
also um emailed us um some reports that
have been done by other folks so there's
um
here this
the
okay okay all right so and this has been
emailed to us so if we want to um you
know look at it um and then figure out
um about maybe doing a work session and
uh talking about what we think should be
included in the report um what kind of
recommendations did you say a work
session yeah I okay so you're
potentially you're considering another
meeting before before
November 1 yeah I I honestly well I've
been told that there aren't um there
aren't there aren't report police who
are going to come and arrest us if we
don't get it in by November
1st I mean I I voted for the law I
should probably follow it I also think
it may be possible that we would come up
with one simple piece of legislation fil
by the deadline in
November
well I was not reelected so this will be
my
last meeting of as of the committee
so
um I won't be filing anything right but
the uh so I just wanted to give kind of
my thoughts or whatever as um and make
like find out what's going to be in the
report or have some contribution I guess
to the the the um findings
recommendations
I I
can I guess less is more but but it also
seems like more is more so last time you
were talking about you wanted to have
like a lot of stuff in your report and
this report is obviously kind
of it's really trying to condense it
down to like you know one page
or maybe maybe the p a page of our notes
like maybe six pages or something like
that not not uh you know the yeah all of
the information yeah so I you know we
received a lot of information you know
testimony Etc so um I think we can write
a report and then um have you know an
appendix or a denda that has all of the
materials that we you know when I when I
was thinking about it I thought you know
the report should include a list of
everyone that we received testimony from
okay and then some um important things
that we've discovered like the lack of
affordability the elective
accessibility um and then some
opportunities um and you know um
barriers to creating new forms of
housing for people with dis disabilities
and then you know as far as
recommendations you know looking into
those things and um I think yes it's
possible that we could have
some there's a section here for process
and procedures right and it's part of
our charge to to talk with certain
people so we can kind of address that
we've met some of those requirements in
the law um if and uh by listing out
those people that that came finding
recommendations I think that two it's
kind of twofold if there is anything
that we know that there is you know
legislation that we think that is
appropriate um that could be one section
and then also kind
of just thinking about going where we go
in the next year right and and how we
want to dig
deeper um
you I think you know for example my my
thoughts on the the definition of of
facility and how it was brought up last
time that that uh by someone I think
that the uh the
facility may
be is is kind of uh
based on the number of
rooms or the beds or um the number of
people staying in there
um and in one
structure versus in kind of like a
separate apartment or something like
that so you know this like the the
example that was given here today right
where they they rented something from
someone if those if they rented if let's
say they rented a three-bedroom
apartment and so they had three people
in that building right and then they
happened that they worked well with that
landlord they rented a different
three-bedroom apartment happens to be in
the same building that I think would qu
make them qualify for um needing L
needing lure I don't know but I I think
that because it's under the same
roof um even though it's two separate
contracts or whatever um it may be
something that this committee may want
to dig in more about how are they
specifically
defining uh the the facility and the
scope of the facility kind of a thing
and so that's one of the things uh that
I think is it it's a little archaic or
or kind of in the weeds but it's
something that I think is having
significant ramifications and if you
know uh if the company that was that was
here earlier had a a business or had had
someone that they were able to work with
that could achieve that why should that
why should we put be putting additional
barriers or whatever in the way I I
think that that's something that could
have an impact on what you know if they
if they opened up another facility in
that in that um that place so it's just
something that that I think is like an
example of where I think this committee
could go deeper into the weed yeah I I
agree but I think we
should probably have a work session or a
zoom meeting where we try to come up
with um our what we want in the
preliminary report and then um
you know plan to to go deeper into some
issues maybe take action on anything we
that something simple we could tackle
this year and then um plan it out do we
have to vote to accept it or is it kind
of just like you submit it to the clerk
or something like that and that's it
say
Okay okay so it sounds like a work
session
then if we're if we're taking a vote
then we have to be here and it has to be
right I mean if we voting then there's
meeting oh yes yes I mean we are meeting
right now I'm
talking yeah but if we weren't going to
to write the yeah yes so looking so
so as so either we decide it now or if
we want to work on it you know for a
little while then we would have to have
a
meeting well I'm fine with that how how
are you okay with that with which one um
one with coming back I'm fine with
coming back
um
uh before the
first
29 the the next Tuesday yeah
yeah yeah we could just have it as a
work session and and and then at the end
of the meeting we'll just plan to um
like have our ideas hopefully uh ahead
of time and then kind of discuss them
and and then we
can like do a mockup of like what like
the bullet points or something like that
we don't have to have it like all typed
out or whatever like she said it long as
the gist is there and then can fill it
out you know I'll just put put you know
together a a draft I do want to include
the you know who we heard from
absolutely because that sounds good in
the original legislation there was a
list that representative Reed provided
for us of who we supposed to talk to um
and we did hear from most of them but
yeah so yeah so let's plan on on coming
back here next Tuesday and I'll I'll
just put up kind of
a you know sort of a draft for us to
work off okay and based on the um the
template that we've been provided and
looking at some of these other reports
like you know like some of them are more
substantial than others she only had one
copy of this but she has emailed it to
us so I think what we're looking at is
something more like this that will have
attachments to it and so forth okay okay
all right that sounds good uh so are you
thinking one o' 1:30 again yep 130
sounds good can you make sure that
yeah um yeah I wasn't saying that we had
to notice that we're gonna make a
decision no that's not what I was trying
to
say um but I
wouldn't we
just let everyone know that we're not
necessarily going to be soliciting
comment and stuff like that so so they
don't have to show up if they don't
really uh if they're unless they just
want to hear us talk to each
other but but feel free
to um I think that that's that's all
that I had so I could make a motion to
adjourn do I have a second
second okay um without objection the
meeting is adjourned all right so good
good